したがって、日本語の t は英語の t
と同じでなければなりません。
少なくともこれは
、日本語の教科書や日本語の教室で通常教えられていることです
が
、実際にはそうではありません。
日本茶とイングリッシュ ティーの 1
つは吸引ですが
、t の音と kmp の音を言うときに吐き出す空気の量のよう
なものですが、吸引は
少し複雑
で、詳しく説明しました。 長いので
、そのビデオを下にリンクしますが、
他のことは実際には舌の配置
です。たとえば、英語のお茶でテッドという名前を言う場合、
テッドという名前を数回言ってみて
ください。 舌の
先が
テッド・
テッドに触れているところは、歯槽堤と呼ばれるものに触れてい
ます。上の前歯のすぐ後ろにある隆起のようなものです。
テッド・テッド
、その知識を持ってもう一度言ってみると、ほぼ確実にそうなるでしょう。
日本
茶では、舌先が
上の前歯の後ろに接触し
、次に舌の刃に接触することに注意してください。これが舌先である場合
、舌先のすぐ後ろの領域のようなものです。
ここで、舌の刃が
ここにあります
[音楽]
また
、上部の舌の先端のすぐ後ろですが、舌の先端
は
上の前歯の後ろに触れ、次に
舌の刃に触れています 歯槽堤に触れている
ので、その意味で、日本茶
は
英国茶よりも舌の位置が
少しだけ
前方にあるだけです.
面白いことに、この単語の
重要な部分を言うと、私の舌がより多く見えるという違いを実際に見ることができる
ので
、今から数回言いますが
、少し誇張しています
効果については少しですが、もう一度見ると
ネイティブ スピーチのこのより前の舌の位置については、あなたはそれに気付くでしょう。
私は留学中に日本人の友人と会話をしていて、
実際にその単語を言おうとし
ていたので、例として使用しています。彼
は あなたの t の音は少し
ずれていると言って、私は私の t の音を
言いまし
た。 ああ、彼の舌は
その2番目のものでより前方にある
ようでした。彼の舌
が、彼の上部の前歯の側面にある彼の側面の間のようなものです。
これも
また、舌の配置が
異なるためです。 要約すると
、日本茶は舌先
が上の前歯の裏
に、舌の刃が
歯槽堤に接しているのですが
、これは舌先だけが接している英国茶とは異なり
ます。
少なくともアメリカ英語での歯槽堤
これが役に立ったことを願っています 以下にリンクさ
れているパトレオンで日本語の発音を教えて
います もし誰か
があなたの日本語研究の幸運に興味を持っているなら、
またすぐに皆さんと話してください